dans plusieurs grandes villes
canadiennes des crimes violents contre
des personnes sans-abri font de plus
souvent de plus en plus souvent la
manchette et la police de Calgary les
considère maintenant comme des crimes
haineux qu'est-ce que ça change cette
classification mais pour en parler en
juin à René Veret un avocat criminaliste
un ancien procureur au DPCP bonjour René
mais est-ce qu'il y a une définition
juridique à cette expression là crime
prévoit une liste effectivement
d'éléments de facteurs qui peuvent être
considérés ici notamment sur l'âge
effectivement la couleur l'origine
ethnique il y a plusieurs éléments qui
sont mentionnés bon alors on comprend
donc si Calgary estimé que les crimes
violents contre les sans-abris sont
motivés par la haine c'est évidemment
les policiers qui enquêtent c'est eux
qui recueillent la preuve la preuve est
utilisant les procès qu'est-ce que ça
change dans le travail des policiers qui
considèrent maintenant certains types de
crimes comme étant haineux qu'est-ce
qu'il doit faire de plus dans leurs
enquêtes je pense que les policiers vont
se mettre leur dossier effectivement
procureur en leur présentant la
situation comme étant un crime qui est
commis à l'égard de personnes
vulnérables et les tribunaux ont
toujours été sévères je vous disais à
l'égard des gens qui commettent des
crèmes à l'égard des personnes
vulnérables le code NET protège
notamment les conjoints de faits les
enfants mineurs protègent beaucoup de
gens qui sont vulnérables donc les
tribunaux les juges sont vraiment très
sévères je vous dirai lorsque les crimes
sont commis à de ces gens-là et
d'ailleurs on le sait dans plusieurs cas
de police notamment à Montréal il y a
des escouades spécialisés dans les corps
de police pour les crimes haineux qui
n’enquête que là-dessus donc c'est
quelque chose qui existe de plus en plus
un peu partout là
à mon avis ça va certainement considérer
par les juges par les tribunaux c'est
kremlocks sont commis à l'égard de ces
gens qui sont je le rappelle vulnérables
donc qui méritent qu'on leur accorde une
protection supplémentaire bon évidemment
là on peut se demander est-ce que ça
mène à des accusations qui sont
différentes parce que des fois de fait
c'est des voix de fait une tentative
demeure peu importe la motivation ça
demeure une tentative de meurtre mais si
une composante de N ou de préjugés à
l'endroit de cette personne là est-ce
que l'accusation change ou c'est
seulement au bout du compte que ça
paraît
l'accusation demeure la même ce qui va
changer c'est au stade la peine donc au
stade la détermination de la peine le
juge pourra donc imposer une peine plus
sévère contre lui du fait que ces crimes
là ont été commis à l'égard de Jean
vulnérables bon c'est ça alors le Code
criminel le prévoit tout à l'heure vous
en avez numérique quelques-uns de ces
critères là l'origine ethnique la
religion il y a des crimes et nous qui
sont faciles à identifier si on paye une
croix gammée là sur une synagogue ou peu
importe sur une pierre tombale ça tombe
sous le sens mais à l'égard des
sans-abris est-ce qu'il faudrait
l'ajouter sur dans le Code criminel ou
si c'est juste par ce sont des critères
parmi un certain nombre donc le statut
de sans-abri n'est pas nommé mais ça
empêche pas qu'on puisse plaider que ce
soit nul
mais je pense qu'on pourrait rajouter
mais la liste isabelle est quand même
pas limitée
[Musique]
alors à mon avis ça pourrait entrer dans
cette catégorie là justement de
personnes vulnérables qui méritent une
protection plus grande c'est sûr que à
Calgary on a eu un certain exemples et
les policiers avaient eu comme preuve il
y avait un des accusés qui s'était
confié à quelqu'un du genre à long à la
chasse aux sans-abris ou c'est quelque
chose du genre et c'était confié qu'il
le faisait pour ça mais il y a pas juste
à Calgary qu'on a ça on en a vu ailleurs
est-ce qu'on peut imaginer que il y a
d'autres services de police qui
pourraient tout à coup décider
d'agrandir un peu l'assiette si on peut
dire
mais moi je pense que tous les corps de
police devraient suivre cette trace là
et considérer ces crimes là comme étant
des crimes plus sérieux plus graves qui
méritent une peine plus grande et je
suis convaincu que la poursuite va aussi
effectivement jouer son rôle à ce niveau
là les tribunaux également je vous
mentionner tantôt à ces gens-là méritent
je le disais tantôt une plus grande
protection et mérite que qu'on soit
sévère à l'égard des gens qui commettent
des crimes à l'égard de ces gens-là
parce que effectivement on le plaidera
au moment de la peine donc il faut
d'abord et avant tout que la personne
soit déclarée coupable du crime lui-même
que ce soit votre fait ou autre chose
par rapport à l'accusation qui est porté
un vote fait demeure un voie de fait
mais par contre au niveau de la peine on
va certainement constater comme étant un
facteur aggravant un crime commis à
l'égard de personnes comme celle-là
pendant on va suivre ça parce que on en
a vu un exemple à Toronto où il y a 8
adolescentes qui s'en sont pris à un
itinéraire les exemples se multiplient
alors c'est un peu inquiétant donc on va
évidemment
s'en sont prêts un homme effectivement
qui était bon qui était vulnérable alors
on suit ça merci beaucoup de nous en
avons parlé à René merci
en entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici
RDI
[Musique]